febuary is a romantic month and Sony is  showing us some love with the latest  batch of PlayStation Plus games I'm Tony  this is a GameSpot news update and this  is your February games lineup  first up ps4 is getting a pretty big  first party offering with  LittleBigPlanet 3 the latest in the  cutesy level building series ps4 is also  getting the pixel art action game not a  hero  ps3 is getting the puzzling Anna  extended edition and the quirky neon  multiplayer games star wall PS Vita is  getting the retro looking platformer  ninja sancai DX and the tricky cube  based puzzle game torque L for the  record both of those games plus star  wall can also be played on ps4 thanks to  cross by so you have plenty of options  there the new PS Plus offerings will go  live on Tuesday February 7 until then  you can still grab January's free games  including day of the tentacle remastered  and Titan souls and to keep up with all  the latest playstation news you're  already in the right place  you